Hello movie fans!
Do you love impressing your friends with your
unrivalled movie trivia?
Do you know which actors portrayed every single
character in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
franchise, and you might even know which year
every movie in the Hellraiser franchise was
released, but what about those lesser known
facts from behind the scenes?There are a lot
of facts about movies that might just take
you by surprise - and that's what this video
is all about.
Here's our latest edition of twenty rapid
fire behind the scenes movie facts...
Thor: Ragnorok
Taika Waititi will direct Thor: Ragnarok,
which will make the movie the first Marvel
Studios franchise to have three different
directors for each film.
Kenneth Branagh directed Thor and Alan Taylor
directed Thor: The Dark World.
Deadpool
The full body make up that Ryan Reynolds had
to wear as Deadpool took eight hours to apply.
Once it was applied, he wasn't allowed to
either sit or lie down.
The Angry Birds Movie
The Angry Birds Movie is the most costly movie
to ever come out of Final.
It had a production budget of $80 million,
and there was an additional $100 million spent
on marketing.
Alien: Covenant
The 2007 sequel to Prometheus was originally
going to be called Alien: Paradise Lost, but
the title was changed to Alien: Covenant.
The Conjuring 2
Director James Wan was offered a "life altering"
amount of money to direct 2017's Fast 8, but
he turned the opportunity down to direct The
Conjuring 2.
He said he felt "rejuvenated to tell a scary
story one more time", having previously directed
the first Conjuring movie and two of the Insidious
installments.
Rogue One: A Star Wars Story
The female lead role of Jyn Erso in Rogue
One: A Star Wars Story, which ultimately went
to Felicity Jones, was auditioned for by a
pair of actress sisters in Kate and Rooney
Mara.
Wonder Woman
Zack Snyder - of Batman v Superman directorial
fame - will cameo in the first Wonder Woman
solo movie as a World War I soldier.
He will also be credited as a producer on
the movie.
The Hateful Eight
2015's brilliant The Hateful Eight was originally
planned to be much longer than the final version.
Early test screenings had a runtime of over
three hours and actually included an intermission.
Creed
Sylvester Stallone is a big fan of English
Premier League soccer team, Everton.
As a result, some of the crowd scenes in Creed
were filmed at the Everton versus WBA game
on a cold Monday night in England.
10 Cloverfield Lane
Throughout the entirety of the filming of
10 Cloverfield Lane, the movie's cast weren't
told the title of the movie.
The idea was (obviously) to keep the whole
thing as secret as possible.
Spider-Man: Homecoming
Donald Glover has recently been confirmed
to appear in Spider-Man: Homecoming, which
is very exciting.
He's the second Community actor to star in
a Spider-Man movie, as Joel McHale had a cameo
in Spider-Man 2.
Krampus
2015's Krampus was originally meant to be
released on the 25th of November, but it was
delayed until the 4th of December to coincide
with the Krampusnacht - a traditional Austrian
festival held on the 5th of December to celebrate
the Krampus coming to punish naughty children.
Sausage Party
When Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg's hilarious-looking
Sausage Party is released in August of 2016,
it will become the first American R-rated
computer animated film since Aqua Teen Hunger
Force Colon Movie Film for Theaters in 2007.
Ant-Man
Paul Rudd was the unexpected star of 2015's
Ant-Man when he portrayed the titular Scott
Lang.
When he told his nine-year-old daughter that
he was going to be Ant-Man, she said, "Wow,
I can't wait to see how stupid that'll be."
Dirty Grandpa
Dirty Grandpa's theatrical poster sees Robert
De Niro lifting Zac Efron onto his back.
Whilst promoting the movie on Instagram, Efron
himself confirmed that De Niro did this without
any help or prompting.
Spectre
Spectre was the first Bond film not to feature
the iconic trumpet playing of Derek Watkins.
Ever since 1962's Dr. No, Watkins had featured
on the soundtrack of every single Bond outing.
However, he passed away shortly after the
release of Skyfall.
The Secret Life of Pets
Althought they are all big stars with multiple
movies to their names, The Secret Life of
Pets marks the feature animation debut of
several of its key cast, including Louis CK,
Eric Stonestreet and Kevin Hart.
Warcraft
With orcs being key members of the cast of
Warcraft, an "Orcish" dialect was created
specifically for the movie.
Suicide Squad
Suicide Squad's release date in 2016 will
come exactly fifty years after the Joker first
appeared in live action, back in 1966 when
Cesar Romero portrayed the character on both
the small and big screen.
Suicide Squad
Will Smith shaved his head and spent time
training with Navy SEALS and Army Rangers
in order to prepare for his role as Deadshot
in Suicide Squad.
He practiced firing a Glock 9mm handgun and
an AR-15 rifle, and was apparently a very
quick learner.
Thanks for watching our latest list of 20
rapid fire behind the scenes movie facts.
Did you know about any of these?
Which other great movie facts do you know
of?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.